un oeuf normale a toujours un intérieur
bien à lui et il arrive qu'un meuf est
deux ou plusieurs intérieur à lui tout
seul c'est parra chez les shadoks non
seulement c'était pas pareil mais
c'était quasiment le contraire de sorte
que le même intérieur pour des raisons
d'un mur obscures se mettait dans
plusieurs zones et pouvant pont des deux
à la fois moins il y avait d'intérieur
dans chaque et moi il y avait des
shadoks c'était fatal
voilà ce qui s'était passé ça c'était de
la faute du chat d'oc population etc
avaient pas surveiller ses intérieurs le
chat d'oc population peser finement
remarquer qu'il avait été nommé ministre
de la population seulement et pas
ministre de l'intérieur piètre excuse
et pendant ce temps là les shadoks
impopulaire a perdu au parlement
continuer à explorer à un peuple et la
lune